讓所有國家央行都聞風喪膽的名字
喬治索羅斯
他的目光呢
也落到了台灣這一座小島上面
但是呢
這一次他沒有想到的是
劇本呢
沒有照著他熟悉的模式
繼續演下去
大家早安晚安晚安
歡迎大家收看這次輪到誰
我是艾倫
今天呢
要跟大家回到了1990年代
尋找呢
現在被稱為金融巨額的
那一位有名的人物
在整個金融史上呢
如果只能挑一個讓所有國家央行都聞風喪膽的名字
那絕對是喬治·索羅斯
在那個年代的金融市場
索羅斯這個名字基本上就是全球宏觀對沖的代名詞
索羅斯的操作模式很純粹
就是只要發現一個國家
它的經濟基本面又出現了一些問題
而官方政策又要硬要維持原狀的話
它就會動用海量的資本去衝擊這個失衡點
也就是說它就是找BUG來獲取利益
那我们回到了1992年的秋天
他算准了英国经济根本就撑不住高汇率
单枪匹马就在伦敦抛售了上百亿美元的英镑
逼得不可一世的这个英格兰银行投降了
也因为这个战役让他名流轻史
更被封为打垮央行的男人
而五年之后也就是1997年的夏天
索罗斯把这套推演的模型搬到了亚洲
他发现了泰国呢
这个外债高筑外汇存底基本上已经见底
于是呢他就在曼谷点燃了导火索
放空泰铢直接引起了席卷全亚洲的金融海啸
随后呢在马来西亚
在印尼
在菲律宾
甚至是南韩啊
都有深陷这一个危机
而索罗斯呢
接着呢又把庞大的资金
大举进入到香港的会市
展开了金星动魄的骨会博弈
同时呢
他的目光也落到了台灣這座小島上面
把這個邏輯放到了台灣的新台幣身上
但是這一次他沒有想到的是
劇本沒有照著他熟悉的模式繼續演下去
所而知會盯上台灣從宏觀對中的角度來講
其實是非常符合邏輯的
甚至可以說是一個勝率極高的交易
當時的背景在整個東南亞貨幣全面狂貶
這個泰銖或者說韓元蝙蝠甚至來到了三成跟四成而台灣是一个高度依赖出口制造业的经济体如果周围邻国的货币商品都变便宜了
新台币如果死守在高档
台湾的电子厂、传产工厂的这些订单
马上就会被周边的国家给抢光
所以索罗斯他算准了一件事情
市场上对新台币的贬值预期
一定会像野火一样越烧越旺
但当时索罗斯毕竟是这种大司级的操盘手
那不會就傻傻的拿幾百億美元去現貨市場去硬砸
而它選擇的是一個當時極為高效
甚至有點隱密
還不是非常有名的工具
叫做NDF 無本金交割遠期外匯
當時台灣境內的外匯指定銀行就是DBU
它是允許乘坐NDF的
而外資機構只要拿出一點點保證金大概5-10%
不需要真的把整筆資金匯進台灣
就能跟銀行簽訂大額的遠期放空合約
到了約定的時間雙方也不用交割實體的本金
只要根據匯率的價差、多退、少補、結算美元就可以了
這意味著索羅斯陣營只要準備十幾億美元的籌碼
就能在台灣金融體系上撬動明目本金高達百億美元的空頭部位
在風暴初期事情的發展也非常順利
就像索羅斯寫的腳本這樣子在走
市場恐慌情緒開始做蔓延
大家都想把台幣換成美金
台灣央行一開始是試圖要阻扁的在線或市場連續拋售美元
短短幾個月就消耗了幾十億美元的外匯存體
而到了1997年的10月
央行評估不能再這樣盲目的消耗下去了
決定放手讓匯率由市場的供需去做決定
新台幣也隨即一路走弱
從29塊一路滑到了34塊附近
所得是開局基本上是獲取了非常大的優勢
然而排局進行到這裡
台灣這邊的陣營悄悄換了主將
在1998年2月台灣發生了一個震驚社會的一個大源空難
時任央行的總裁許願東不幸在這個空難中續職了
而在整個國家金融體系面臨巨大外部壓力
跟內部震盪的危機關頭
彭懷南這個14A的總裁接任了中央銀行總裁
當時許多的外資機構都在觀察
這位新上任的這個央行總裁
面對席捲全亞洲的金融風暴到底會怎麼樣的出牌
如果台灣央行跟這個泰國一樣
為了維持匯率面子再度大舉消耗外匯存體去硬檔那索羅斯就能像過去一樣透過源源不絕的空單把對方慢慢的耗死但是呢彭海南他沒有急著在現貨市場砸錢
他做的第一件事情
就是調出所有外匯銀行的交易報表
把每筆資金的來龍去賣
借貸的結構都一筆一筆的查清楚
很快呢彭海南就抓到了這一個問題的核心
索羅斯這一套放空架構看似非常龐大
但他最脆弱的動脈
就是建立在台灣本土銀行乘坐的槓桿之上
外資其實是在借台灣本土銀行的資金管道
來反向放空新台幣
那麼既然看見了這一點
那其實根本就不需要拿真金白銀去跟它打消耗戰
而在1998年5月22日的早晨
台灣銀行就發布一道震撼市場的公告
那自節日期全面禁止國內指定銀行
乘坐新台幣無本金交割遠期的外匯
就是NDF的業務
而這道禁令一發布
當然整個外匯市場就炸了鍋了嘛
站在索羅斯的交易團隊角度來看
这个根本就是个晴天逼利
他们原本可以在台湾境内银行
以极低的成本不断斩齐合约
滚动杠杆的部位
但现在境内的水龙头它直接锁起来了
外资如果想继续玩NDF
那就只能跑到海外的境外金融中心
就是OBU去做乘坐
可是海外的市场
根本就没有新台币实体的清算体系
借贷台币跟调度资金的成本会非常的庞大
而不仅如此
台湾央行在现货市场也展开了比较灵活的游击战
央行不再使手某一个固定价位
而是每天不定时不定点的进场调节
甚至经常在收盘前的最后15分钟
突然进场
突袭就是拉台会价
而这个会让空投阵营非常难受
索罗斯手上的空单
每天在下午结算的时候
不仅要面临着大幅攀升的借贷利息
账面上还得承受央行尾盘带来的浮动亏损
这个时候索罗斯的团队就一定要停下脚步了
来审视一下我们台湾
征座岛屿的真正底牌
那也这么一看呢他们有发现一件事情
台湾呢跟之前他们拿下的泰国是不太一样的
第一个泰国呢当初之所以崩溃
是因为国内民间还有企业呢借了太多的短期美元外债
外汇存体一旦用完呢就会引发债务违约
但当时呢台湾几乎是没有外债的
企业的体质是相对健康
再来第二个台湾当时手里呢握有外汇存体超过800亿美元
是高居全球前列
手上呢有非常雄厚的现金流储备换句话说啊对手不仅弹药充足而且防禦工事非常兼顾基本上短期內沒有被擠兌破產的可能那麼現在的情況就擺在眼前槓桿的管道被官方直接封鎖
海外持商的利息每天都要再燒
那匯率波動又不再呈現單邊下跌
而對手現在籌碼又非常厚
如果繼續在台灣市場堅持下去
就會變成一場代價非常高
勝率變低的一個資金耗損戰
最後索羅斯陣營在市場上分批去結清了
新台幣的部位,任賠虧損
這場新台幣攻防戰也成為索羅斯輝煌的交易歷史中
是極具代表性的一場失利案例
這一段發生在1998年博弈故事雖然落幕了
但是它留下來的一些值得思考的重點
還是非常值得參考的喔
第一個,邏輯看對了不代表交易就一定會賺錢
從總經的角度來看
索羅斯判斷亞洲風暴會對台灣的出口造成貶值的壓力
這個邏輯本質上是沒有錯的
但是他忽略了台灣資產負債表的結構
低外債跟高外匯存體
讓這個市場具備了比較強的抗壓能力
而做交易也是一樣
如果你看對了趨勢方向
但如果忽略了對手的籌碼厚度跟資金的結構
還是可能會在震盪中因為成本過高而出場
再來第二個永遠要對於規則改變
保持警惕
任何將交易勝率建立在特定金融工具
或者漏洞或者說寬鬆監管上的策略
都會隱藏著比較巨大的政策風險
當監管機構認定市場的穩定受到威脅的時候
他們是有能力直接調整遊戲規則的
一旦支撐你策略的核心工具如果被抽走
原本急劇吸引你的槓桿優勢
瞬間就會反噬成為巨大的流動性負擔
再來第三個要懂得何時停損
才能在市場上活得更久
很多人只看見了索羅斯放空英鎊泰鎚時的大獲全勝
但卻忽略了他在台灣碰壁時那種
毫不拖泥帶水的停損狀態
在教育的市場裡沒有任何人能夠保證自己永遠看對
而當核心的假設不再成立
持有的成本過高的時候
能夠壓下自尊心果斷的認賠離場
保護好Z的資本才有機會去打下一場仗
這個才是真的能夠在市場長存的真正關鍵
這個就是1998年金融巨波
索羅斯跟台灣新台幣交鋒的完整故事
聽完這個故事
大家對於當初這些央行果斷關閉NTF
或者說索羅斯的操作策略選擇有什麼看法呢
歡迎可以在底下留言跟我們討論
喜歡這支影片的朋友記得幫我訂閱按讚
开启小铃铛
我是艾伦
我们现在一起见
拜拜